almost all American journalism is
controlled by a few massive corporations
news voice is a one-of-a-kind mobile app
that tracks the bias and corporate
interests that infuse the news stories
we consume every day and it's completely
free to use go to news voice dot-com
slash Pakman to download it ok we have
an update sort of on this issue of
testing for the beer bug as we are
referring to it you know beer Corona you
guys get it um
the back story has been we need to start
testing and we need to start testing not
only symptomatic people but we if we
really want to handle this properly from
a public health perspective we need to
do what South Korea did which is you
identify an area where you know you have
a certain number of cases and then you
test a huge number of people even people
who are asymptomatic you test them for
antibodies to see what is the likely
number of real cases this gets us a more
accurate death rate this communicates to
people even if they have no reason to
think that they might be contagious that
they actually are despite not
experiencing symptoms so we need to test
to get updated numbers we need to test
to prevent spread we need to test as a
matter of public health the w-h-o
offered a test to the United States the
Trump administration said no the CDC is
going to develop our own test that
failed so now we are slowly I guess
getting more and more tests from the
w-h-o but the question is how many
people have been tested they Trump said
it's a beautiful test that anybody can
get turns out that doctors say no we
can't get the test I'm having a hard
time getting the tests say so many
doctors so Secretary of Health and Human
Services Alex Azhar goes on CNN and is
asked so how many tests have been done
what's going on with the tests you know
Trump said it's a beautiful test that's
widely available
Alexes R has no idea and he starts
quoting the AEI the American Enterprise
Institute take a look at this how many
Americans have been tested at this point
we don't know exactly how many because
hundreds of thousands of our tests have
gone out to private labs and hospitals
that currently do not report in to CDC
we're working with the CDC and those
partners to get an eye
reporting system up and running
hopefully this week where we would be
able to get that data to keep track of
how many were testing we think we've got
throughput at the moment probably 10,000
a day or it could be getting tested by
the end of the week 20,000 a day
according to a study by AEI that I that
I heard about we've got now 2.1 million
tests available at 1.1 million have
shipped so again tests available means
very little if doctors don't have them
they might have 10,000 tests sitting
somewhere they might have 10 million
tests sitting somewhere it doesn't
really matter if the tests aren't
available why is the Secretary of Health
and Human Services who is coordinating
this reading reports from a conservative
think-tank the American Enterprise
Institute assuming that's who he's
referring to about how many people might
be able to test you're supposed to know
is anyone else concerned that the
Secretary of Health and Human Services
when asked about a number he should know
independently says well I read from the
AEI that by week's end we might be able
to test 10 or 20,000 people a day the
official number of people tested as of
yesterday is 8,500 okay
that's 26 people per million in the
population that is insanely low Bahrain
is testing nearly 5,000 people per
million we're testing 26 South Korea is
testing 40 100 per million we're testing
26 in Hong Kong they're testing more
than 2,000 people per million we are
testing 26 those countries are getting
this under control we are not and we
have tested 26 people per million
Trump part of this as Trump thinks that
a larger number of cases will make him
look bad now of course it will expose
that we when he said we're unlikely to
have many cases we likely have somewhere
you know the official numbers over a
thousand the real number is probably
between three and six thousand based on
estimates I'm looking at Trump thinks
more cases will make him look bad he
should it will make him look like a liar
but we know he's a liar he should
understand that if you get more cases
that lowers the death rate one of the
things Trump said early on is I think
the death rate is going to be much lower
than 3.4 percent that may well be the
case three point four seems high and
this is good
the South Korean death rate is 0.7
percent the u.s. death rate so far is
0.3% and it would be lower if we knew
the full number of cases because clearly
it's more than a thousand cases there's
a few other positive things maybe that I
want to mention going on with all of
this
Italy finally had a day with fewer new
cases than the day before Italy has been
out of control with this and and they're
in really problematic shape in terms of
deaths full country lockdown it's very
bad in Italy but Italy had leading up to
yesterday eight straight days of more
cases each day they finally had a
reduction in the number of new cases
yesterday if that continues to go down
that's a good sign we'll know in about a
week or 10 days number two
China is rapidly clearing 1000 to 1500
active cases per day so China had this
huge number of infections to begin with
but for the last week or so China each
day has only twenty to a hundred new
cases but around a thousand to 1500
people are recovering if that trend
continues you can see how mathematically
that gets rid of it within China if it
doesn't come back in or if things don't
become more problematic so I'm hopeful
because for me this is not political
this is just people I want people to be
healthy and to live and to be okay this
may be an inflection point that we are
getting to where we we may be going in a
good direction that's optimistic we also
might not we'll know more probably
within the next three or four days let
me know where you think this is going
I'm on Twitter at D Pakman we'll take a
break and there is just so much to
discuss today